et pour en parler nous sommes avec
jean-philippe du coin clément mais rudy
de même si vice-président de la région
ile-de-france bonsoir rémy rebeyrotte
député la république en marge de la 3ème
circonscription de saône-et-loire
bonsoir à vous aussi enfin alexis
poulain éditorialistes merci à tous les
trois d'être avec nous pour ce
décryptage première destination possible
donc semaine 1 dans la dernière semaine
de décembre si tout va bien dit jean
castex le premier ministre on le
rappelle inquiétant le feu vert de cette
fameuse agence européenne du médicament
il n'empêche la date a tout de même été
avancé on verra pourquoi un petit peu
plus tard plutôt une bonne nouvelle ou
pas assez prudent rémy rebeyrotte très
bonne nouvelle avec un premier ministre
une grande humilité je suis pas griller
les étapes
les choses progressivement d'abord
l'autorisation européenne sous sous
j'allais dire elle à la pression de
l'ensemble des pays bien sûr des pays
bien sûr que tu es que nous sommes en
mesure de pouvoir commencer la
vaccination il faut pouvoir le faire
mais dans des conditions de sécurité et
une connaissance parfaite de 16
c'est ce qu'a souligné mr effectivement
la france passera près d'un million deux
cent mille vaccin d'ici la fin de
l'année pour pouvoir commencer cette
campagne de vaccination notamment à
destination des plus anciens en
institutions et des personnes les plus
fragiles et des personnels soignants
sont vraiment la volonté du gouvernement
et s'était soumis par les autres
collègues députés
la présentation a été à la fois efficace
et 6 et en même temps extrêmement
organisés de telle sorte que nous
puissions avoir des saignements et ce
soir il nous permet d'avancer
concrètement cette grande campagne de
buzz
vous êtes un député la république en
marche plutôt heureux ce soir est
convaincue par le premier ministre c'est
vrai que l'exercice de pédagogie on
l'aura compris absolument primordiale à
dans cette campagne de vaccination avec
des français en grande majorité très
sceptique vous partager cet optimisme
jean philippe dugoin clément le premier
ministre vous at il convaincu cet après
midi je sais pas s'il faut parler
d'optimisme ou pas ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'il faut avancer sur ce sujet et
avancer rapidement au moins pour les
personnes les plus fragiles qui
souhaitent pouvoir se faire vacciner
les vaccinations ont commencé outre
atlantique outre-manche on va être
globalement sur les même timing en
démarrant lundi prochain je pense que
les autorités sanitaires s'agissant des
mêmes vaccins avons donné les mêmes avis
il n'y a pas de raison que ce qui est
validée en angleterre qui était encore
un pays membre de l'union européenne ya
dix jours ne le soit pas par l'union
européenne donc on va pouvoir avancer
dessus je crois qu'il ya une véritable
nécessité de sécuriser les personnes de
prise à risque on sait que le taux de
risque n'est absolument pas le même sur
des cas graves hors fonction de la
typologie personnes touchées par cette
pandémie
et si on n'arrive pas à avancer sur ce
sujet là je pense qu'on ne sortira pas
de la situation économique et sociétal
qu'on traverse et qui va avoir des
conséquences absolument terrible donc il
faut qu'on avance vite là dessus bon ce
qui a été présenté à l'assemblée
nationale je n'ai pas eu l'ensemble des
débats mais sur ce que j'ai pu en voir
c'était des positions très généraliste
maintenant va falloir rentrer dans le
détail voir comment est-ce que ça va
être déclinée de manière concrète et
puis le sujet qui m'interroge jeune qui
veut plus c'est la durée de vaccination
puisque visiblement on nous dit que sur
les publics non à risque qui
souhaiteraient ou non prioritaires qui
souhaiteraient pouvoir se faire vacciner
on parle de la fin du printemps c'est à
dire quelque chose à six mois ce qui
semble extrêmement long par rapport à
aujourd'hui après chacun est libre on
est sur une vaccination non obligatoire
mais on sait aussi qu'il y a chan un
socle barrière si on veut qu'une
vaccination puisse être efficace par
rapport à un virus donc ma ce qui
m'interroge un petit peu c'est la
question de la méthode déjà et puis de
la durée effectivement cette question de
durée et il faudra attendre le printemps
pour la majorité des français alexis
poulain il n'empêche qu'on attend dans
ce sera un million de personnes visées
dans les ehpad dans un premier temps
sauf que quand on interroge les
directeurs d'ehpad et bien et nous
disons en substance qu'ils ne sont pas
prêts pour l'instant que ça va être un
vrai casse tête à mettre en place
est-ce qu'on se précipite pour la photo
si j'ose dire
c'est un petit peu la course à
l'échalote on voit les premiers avec ça
en russie aux etats-unis en
grande-bretagne et il ne faut pas que la
france soit à la traîne cette fois ci
alors qu on est parent finalement si
près que cela oui j'ai l'impression que
ce sera surtout une campagne de
communication pour la première vague de
vaccins avec les caméras avec l'arrivée
en fanfare du vaccin mais pour ce qui
est de la logistique comme le dit cédric
villani c'est un vrai casse tête c'est
compliqué avec bien sûr le vaccin est
reine qui doit être stocké à moins de 80
degrés avec aussi le dispositif 1 2
qu'elle qui pourra être des ehpad qui
vont être livrés pourront-ils être tout
ce qu'il veut on parle de dix mille
établissements
et puis cette vaccination en deux phases
à une injection et puis une deuxième à
21 jours donc pour l'organisation de
tout ça il faut se préparer mais on n'a
pas l'impression qu'on n'est plus
préparé que ça en france on a vu la
préparation pour les matchs ça a été un
fiasco terrible lord du premier
confinement lors de la première vague là
on risque d'avoir une mise en scène pour
les vaccins avant la fin de l'année pour
dire qu'on fait comme tout le monde
qu'on suit les voisins européens et
qu'on arrive en tête du peloton des pays
qui vaccinent mais ça ne veut pas dire
pour autant que la campagne de
vaccination va commencer en cette fin
d'année je pense que c'est la campagne
de communication sur la campagne de
vaccination qui va commencer et c'est
important je crois pour les différents
partenaires européens de faire cette
campagne ensemble pour pouvoir avoir un
effet levier et pousser les gens à se
faire vacciner en regarder nos voisins
italiens nos voisins allemands le font
sans problème alors allez-y français
vous ne risquez rien alors justement
c'est l'allemagne 1 qui semble-t-il a
pressé le pas et qui demande à l'ordre
d'aller plus vite à l'image des anglais
écouter janssens panneaux ministre
allemand de la santé
nous voulons un examen approfondi
une approbation ordonnée et en même
temps un examen rapide nos autorités
nationales comme d'autres soutiennent au
mieux les autorités européennes
notre objectif est une approbation avant
noël nous voulons toujours commencer à
vacciner cette année en allemagne avant
la fin de l'année c'est une bonne
nouvelle que l'approbation puisse être
accordée le 23 décembre dans l'état
actuel des choses c'est à dire si les
données qui sont actuellement traités
sont disponibles
nous pouvons être optimistes sur le fait
que l'approbation pourra être accordée
le 23 décembre ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle pour l'ensemble de l'union
européenne les ministres allemand à
l'instar de la chancelière qui demandait
qu'on accélère ne pas du coup la date de
la réunion
la commission européenne a été avancée
au 21 décembre
on sait de rémy rebeyrotte d'une
certaine manière à la pression allemande
alors que beaucoup de français
souhaiteraient de la prudence et de la
lenteur même peut-être dans ce dossier
tant ils sont sceptiques
on sait n'a aucune pression particulière
venir les allemands mais comme nous dès
que nous serons en situation de baptiser
leur père moi je suis toujours fasciné
on communie on nous dise une campagne de
communication si on communie alors là on
nous dit mais vous ne communiquez pas en
campagne de communication c'est que tout
simplement on va pouvoir commencer à
vacciner avec une organisation sur
lequel le gouvernement ne se pense pas
qu'à partir de ce soir
imaginez bien que depuis plusieurs mois
le gouvernement travaille avec nos
homologues sur les techniques
logistiques les manières de quoi
approvisionner les centres et mettre en
place la campagne de vaccination à jour
elle ira quand même que cette crise
c'est une formidable
j'allais dire démonstration l'europe un
sens la manière dont nous avons pu gérer
au plan européen que ce soit d'ailleurs
les questions économiques et financières
les questions d'organisation globale et
là sur la vaccination
la possibilité de pouvoir travailler
ensemble et donc d'avoir les meilleures
conditions dans ce premier raid 5
c'est autant de démonstrations sida
était encore besoin non seulement de
l'unité et minuti l'idée d'une union
européenne liste de sa capacité au
niveau du continent après nice et des
choses et quand je regarde ce qui s'est
passé sur d'autres continents et
notamment sur le continent américain
toujours pas close et yo tout à faire
passer même si nous sommes tous
confrontés à une crise d'une extrême
alors évidemment il ya encore pas mal de
questions le premier ministre la met lui
même je propose de regarder cette
infographie sur les six vaccins pré
commandé par l'union européenne il y en
a 3 ans vous les voyez à gauche de votre
écran qui semble au point et dont on
connaît les données et leur efficacité
fighter moderna et astrazeneca trois
autres à droite 1 qui sont en phase iii
ou qui ont pris beaucoup de retard
sanofi curva que johnson & johnson alors
si les données ne sont pas bonnes il y
aura moins de deux vaccins disponibles
nous en inquiéter jean philippe dugoin
clément c'est encore un petit peu la
confusion
oui je crois qu'il ya quand même un
petit peu de marge ce qui est commandé
ces 200 millions de dossiers c'est la
possibilité puisqu'il faut deux doses de
vaccin au moins pour les premiers parce
que les vaccins suivant pour être à
nouveau windows mais c'est la
possibilité de vacciner 100 millions de
personnes ya 67 68 millions de français
on sait par nature la vaccination étant
pas obligatoire qui a une quote part de
la population qui est anti vaccin et qui
ne se fera pas vacciner
on sait encore plus sur ce sujet que il
ya des polémiques à des inquiétudes qui
font que le taux de refus de vaccination
peut être un peu plus élevé donc la
potentialité d'avoir des français qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner qu'il n'ait
pas accès aux vaccins
à mon avis est assez minime le sujet qui
va se poser c'est véritablement l'accès
rapide pour ceux qui souhaitent pouvoir
se faire vacciner
donc c'est effectivement un défi
logistique c'est ce qui était évoqué
tout à l'heure notamment du fait des
températures de conservation et de
transport des vaccins qui sont beaucoup
plus basses que ce qui est fait
d'habitude et donc qui pose des
problèmes techniques importants et sur
lequel je pense que l'état aura besoin
de s'appuyer sur le secteur hospitalier
mais aussi sur les collectivités
territoriales pour pouvoir aller décliné
dans les territoires et puis la deuxième
chose c'est pas une course il ya peu une
course à la recherche enfin il ya peu
une course européenne on voit que pour
le coup on est sur le même calendrier
que les autres grands pays l'union
européenne prévu une date unique pour
mettre en place ces vaccins sur
l'ensemble des pays et on n'est pas sûr
avec ses 1 français en l'espèce le
vaccin français c'est celui qui a pris
six mois de retard on l'aura si tout va
bien en milieu fin d'année proche fin
d'année prochaine
donc c'est pas une course mais c'est
vraiment rassuré les gens parce qu'il ya
quand même une quote part d'inquiétudes
moi je pense qu'on pourrait avoir
intérêt à ce que des membres du
gouvernement se fasse vacciner pour
donner un symbole pour marquer le fait
que ceux qui gouvernent n'ont pas
d'inquiétude sont prêts à le faire je
pense que symboliquement c'est important
d'avoir cette logique d'exemplarité en
tout cas de la part de quelques
ministres et puis au delà de ça c'est
vraiment pouvoir répondre vite pour ceux
qui souhaitent se faire vacciner
ça va être un challenge énorme
effectivement challenge énorme et celui
aussi on l'a dit un vous parliez du
scepticisme des français alexis poulain
ce scepticisme on le rappelle ce chiffre
assez impressionnant 61% des français
qui ne compte pas se faire vacciner est
ce qu'il peut représenter un futur échec
dans cette campagne de vaccination et
par conséquent dans la lutte contre le
virus
je crois que les les français on est le
pays des cartes dont qu'ils attendent
des preuves ils attendent de savoir si
ce vaccin fonctionne parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a des études médicales
certes on a des annonces des
laboratoires 4 3 4 % de taux de réussite
mais on ne sait toujours pas si ce
vaccin permet de stopper la contagion
parions que ça a été dit par jean castex
comme beaucoup de choses qu'on ne sait
pas donc en fait les premières vagues de
vaccination ou permettent de voir si ce
vaccin est efficace quel est son degré
réel d'efficacité une fois qu'il est
dans les populations
et puis aussi quelle est sa durée de
couverture puisque cette technologie est
reine c'est une technologie nouvelle
on se félicitant des avancées de la
science est formidable mais on est au
niveau du prototype puisqu'on a accéléré
toutes les mises sur le marché
que ce soit les autorités de santé que
ce soit les fonds qui ont été débloqués
de manière incroyable souvent ce qui
fait que les vaccins met beaucoup de
temps à être développé c'est qu'il
manque de moyens et que les autorités de
santé mettent beaucoup de temps avant de
donner leur aval là on a tout fait pour
que tout aille très vite parce que le
virus est d'une ampleur inédite mais on
ne sait pas finalement si ça va être
aussi brillant que annoncé sur le papier
donc je crois que les français font
comme tout le monde ils attendent de
voir pour croire et ils préfèrent
attendre sans doute que les preuves de
ces vaccins soit faite
derrière il n'ya pas une volonté
obscurantistes anti-vaccins on est le
pays de pasteur
là on l'a redit suffisamment c'est un
nouveau produit et cette technologie à
rennes mais pas avec 5 comme les autres
donc c'est là qu'est le doute c'est là
qu'est la question sur l'efficacité
quant à la dangerosité je crois que là
elle et minimiser au maximum par les
laboratoires qui ne mettraient pas sur
le marché un produit dangereux par les
autorités de santé également qu'ils vont
faire un travail de suivi des premiers
vaccinés pour être sûr qu'ils aient pas
comme on l'a vu dès plastique faciale
des des problèmes dus à aux injections
de ces vaccins mais le vrai souci
aujourd'hui je crois c'est l'efficacité
réelle des vaccins est ce que ces
vaccins sont là pour redonner la
confiance dans les marchés redonner
confiance dans les populations en ça y
est on va enfin voir le bout du tunnel
de cette pandémie
ou est ce que c'est un médicament qui va
être vraiment efficace et très
rapidement efficace la rémy rebeyrotte
comment regagner la confiance de ses
français parce qu'on a vu ce monsieur
vaccin alain fischer ya plus d'une
semaine nous dire voilà pour l'instant
moi j'ai pas vu les études
bon il a exprimé clairement son
scepticisme est en tout cas il a été
franc ce matin le même alain fischer
l'audience a écouté la sai et
l'efficacité semble acquise on est
optimiste c'est vrai que ça interroge
comment convaincre les français éviter
cette défiance envers ce vaccin est
parfois envers tout simplement les
autorités qu'ils ne croient plus s'est
en d'abord n'avons pas le monopole des
personnes ou à la vaccination même si
c'est très fort nombreux pays c'est vrai
de dire à 10 épisodes précédents où on a
des matinées en masse
oui ça c'est pas la rep est aussi et
puis tout ce qui circule aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux qui effectivement n'est
pas que dans le cadre de la vaccination
d'ailleurs près de 30 ans les jambes je
crois que ce qui est bien c'est qu'on a
choisi les c'est vraiment le volontariat
se faire parce que voilà et je crois que
c'est par l'expérience parce que nous
allons vivre
petit à petit des personnes seront
convaincus qu'il faudra et qu'il est
intéressant de se faire vacciner que ce
même année je joue à ce qui est dit
faudra aussi deux ou se mettre les tarn
et ailleurs ils vont président de
l'association des maires visiblement un
peu de mal à se convaincre lui-même de
la vaccination puisse être l'idée est
que ça incite aussi six collègues faire
le pas voilà je pense qu'à un moment
donné le le bon sens l'emportera
je pense qu'effectivement dans notre
pays vous voir comprendre c'est
quasiment de les dire s'assurer un échec
vaut mieux que par la conviction par les
garanties que nous honorer et chats les
rats effectivement parlera par le pex
d'office qui se penche à l'assemblée
nationale sur les garanties
scientifiques lui considèrent eux il y
aura vraiment un coup sur la vaccination
et que le vaccin serait efficace
c'est l'avis des scientifiques moi je me
réfère à la ville et scientifique
chaque année je me fais vacciner de de
la grippe et c'est vrai que de peggy sue
accises et de la glissade amorcée par
ailleurs eh bien je pense que c'est
moins fort et même cette musique
pour ce qui me concerne en matière de
virologie voilà c'est comme ça que les
choses doivent se faire par l'expérience
et aussi par le bon sens jean philippe
dugoin clément vous justement l'homme de
terrain le maire l'appel du pied de rémy
rebeyrotte vous y êtes sensible il
faudra que les maires en tout cas il ya
un rôle sur le terrain
en de pédagogie auprès des administrés
ça va être une tâche difficile
oui on peut avoir un rôle
d'accompagnement si l'état souhaite que
nous l'ayons si on nous le demande et
qu'on nous présente un cadre avoir
dessus je crois que ça y est on a décrié
depuis des années cette france des 36000
maintenant un peu moins 35 mille
communes c'est aussi un maillage
territorial assez exceptionnel
appuyons-nous dessus l'un des sujets ça
va être de descendre dans les
territoires ça va être d'expliquer ça va
être de relayer dont je pense qu'il faut
s'appuyer sur ces outils qu'on a qui
marche le milieu associatif et quelque
chose le maillage hospitalier
malheureusement depuis des années a
diminué bon réforme après réforme
il reste les communes donc je pense
qu'il faut s'appuyer dessus et moi je
crois vraiment à l'incitation je reviens
sur ce qui a été dit on un pays qui se
cabre quand on veut imposer des choses
là on est dans le pays de 89 et 93
on est dans un pays qui ne supportent
pas la contrainte et où il faut vraiment
il y aller petit à petit permettre à
ceux et ils sont nombreux qui souhaitent
pouvoir se faire vacciner le plus vite
parce qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de gens
parlent de ce qu'ils ont peur des effets
secondaires ou d'une inefficacité mais
il ya aussi des gens qui ont peur du
virus et qui attendent de pouvoir se
faire vacciner
donc je pense qu'il faut cela leur
permettre de se faire vacciner très vite
et puis de proche en proche et bien si
les français tels saint thomas voit
qu'effectivement il ya des progrès en
france il ya des progrès à l'étranger
les choses prendront mais sentent pourra
le faire que par la force de la
conviction et par le retour d'expérience
il ya par exemple
merci jean philippe dugoin clément rémy
rebeyrotte et alexis poulain d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce décryptage après donc
l'audition en fin d'audition
les réponses aux questions des députés
de jean castex à l'assemblée nationale
sur la campagne de vaccination